something i hear a lot it's not just you  but i always hear women like afraid of  being left so in your case it's being  left for a white girl but i've also  heard women being afraid of getting  married and being left for a younger  model or you know someone else but it's  not women who are it's not men who are  leaving it's women  so women leave seventy to eighty percent  of the time if you're college educated  it goes up to ninety percent  so  why as women do we have this fear when  we're the ones that are breaking up our  own homes  got him got it  that was a tumbleweed moment  let me just let me process it yeah  basically yeah women are the ones  leaving relationships